hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear this is my little personal movie
review show
on which i talk about just various
horror movies whatever ones i feel like
watching you know uh no rhyme or reason
to the ones i come up with and uh this
one right here
is kind of an interesting pick this is
one that
i guess i've been seeing it on a lot of
lists like i said because i usually kind
of troll through other people's lists
of uh recommended horror movies and if
something sounds cool or something
sounds kind of like right up my alley
then i'll put it on my list and finally
get around to watching it this is
2016's the neon demon now what i have
heard from a lot of this one
a lot of reviews of this movie was that
both critical and audience reactions to
it were very very mixed some might say
violently mixed in the sense that when
this movie premiered i believe it
premiered at the cannes film festival uh
you got kind of half the audience booing
and half the audience giving like a
standing ovation
and i've often found that movies like
that are kind of like the most
interesting ones to watch
even
when they're not
i don't know even if they're not like
quote unquote objectively good movies or
something like that it's like they're
always something interesting going on
they're usually worth watching um if
only to see like what was causing this
wildly
schizophrenic kind of like reaction to
it so this was one of those movies so of
course you know that i had to
immediately go out and see it now i'm
gonna come down on the side of
i actually
loved this movie
but i can see if it's not for you this
is a very very
arty not as already as some that i've
talked about on here now that i'm
thinking about it
but it is a very kind of like you could
even say it was style over substance
although
i guess that's a fair criticism but in a
lot of ways i think it was intentional
you know or i could say slopes people
thought it was slow or vapid i saw that
word thrown around and stuff like that i
don't agree but like i said i do kind of
feel like if you did have that reaction
to it then you know that's entirely up
to you
but for whatever reason this movie
really there was just something for me
personally there was just something
really hypnotically
compelling about it it probably helped
that i didn't i kind of knew sort of
what what it was about like just in a
very very vague sort of fashion
but i didn't really read any you know
reviews of it or any plot synopsis or
anything like that prior to seeing it so
i just kind of like let it happen so i
didn't really know where it was going
what it was about and and i think that
kind of helped because this movie
is it's classified as a psychological
horror movie which it is
but it's one of those kind of like art
house horror movies where for a long
time
it's not the horror isn't really overt
but then it gets like more and more
uh horrific as it goes on and there's
some stuff in here
uh that's pretty like for general
audiences would be pretty off-putting
let's just say that so let me let me say
now because you know in case you're
thinking about watching this movie and
you're like okay well jenny what are you
talking about like because i don't know
if i want to watch this movie if there's
some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] in it so i'm
going to say right now this is going to
probably be a spoiler review in the
sense that this is a hard movie to talk
about without
saying what happens in it
and as i mentioned if you had been
interested in seeing this movie but are
like yeah i don't want to see it if
there's like really [ __ ] up [ __ ] then
i'm going to have to tell you what the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] is uh so you can
determine like whether you want to watch
it or not i don't know it's kind of like
a catch-22 but uh but yeah so i will say
this probably will have some kind of uh
spoilers but i don't really think even
knowing the plot of this it does have a
plot it does have you know it does have
things happen like action and stuff but
the plot again is not really
the main thread this is almost kind of
like a fairy tale type of movie um
it's very visual it's a very it's more
like a movie that
really needs to be like kind of
experienced it's very heavily
you know as i said heavily visual heavy
heavily symbolic there's it's almost
kind of like an occult type of thing but
not super overtly so you know if i know
i'm trying to become kind of being vague
on purpose this is kind of like like i
said it's kind of a hard movie to talk
about without
spoiling a lot of things about it so
just know that going in now
they're okay so there's the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that's in this um there is a there
is a scene of what is essentially
female on female
necrophilia uh so there's like a
necrophilia scene which a lot of people
were kind of uh grossed out by
uh there is a lot of gore
um as there is cannibalism uh there is
um something for everybody there's
there's a scene at the end with um
uh a girl
a woman barfing up another woman's
eyeball and another woman eating it so
if any of this sounds like it's gonna
gross you out then probably you want to
avoid this like i said for about the
first half of this movie it's a
little over two hours long something
like that about the first half of this
movie it comes across more as
a a very beautiful visual psychological
type of story and then it kind of goes
into like this really shocking like
exploitative type of imagery kind of
reminded me a little bit it reminds me
of um you know if you like stuff by like
gaspar noe or if you liked um
you know [ __ ] like if you like something
like antichrist or something like that
then this would probably this is in that
same kind of wheelhouse uh also has a
little bit of like a surrealist kind of
bent to it has a little bit of a giallo
sensibility to it as well a little bit
david lynchian had some kind of
mulholland drive a little bit of a vibe
to it or lost highway so
if that sounds like something that you
would like that you would probably like
this like i said it seems like there's
like a lot of mixed kind of [ __ ] about
this
so even among people that have liked um
nicholas winding reven's other movies
which
i know a lot of people have seen drive i
haven't seen it yet only god forgives
was another one that he did i saw
bronson which i loved um but he's made
like a bunch of movies and it does
really seem like i don't know if i'd say
that's what he's going for in the sense
that he wants to be shocking or
provocative but
even if he was and i think i've talked
about this before
i'm just kind of like maybe when i was
talking about climax but
you know i i kind of feel like it's a
little bit of an empty criticism to say
that a filmmaker is just deliberately
trying to be provocative i'm like well
what do you want like do you want
somebody like somebody to make a film
that they just don't want anybody to
care about or they're just like oh you
know that was that was pretty good i
mean you know what i mean it's it's
almost kind of like i'm not saying you
have to go out on purpose and like make
a movie like shocking just to be
shocking uh but it's a fine line between
that and kind of like
coming out and making
the movie that you want to make and then
having everybody get like all offended
because you know it's got shocking
content or you think that they're being
shocking just for shocking sake or
whatever i don't know it's kind of like
a whole discussion to have as i said
because i'm a big horror nerd i did not
find any of the sequences in this movie
to be particularly offensive you know
what i mean you necrophilia is yucky and
everything like that but it's like
i don't know it didn't bother me as much
as it maybe would bother somebody else i
guess
you know but i but i'm just a weirdo
like that antichrist also didn't bother
me all that much so
i don't know i don't know if that means
i'm jaded or i'm like a weirdo or
whatever i loved antichrist by the way
but
it didn't like
it didn't disturb me like to my core or
anything like that and this one didn't
either but that's not like a ding on it
so basically this movie
follows a young girl named jessie
who's played by elle fanning
now she's only 16 years old
and she travels out to la and um she's
going to be a model although she goes to
you know the the agency or whatever and
they tell her you know
tell everybody you're 19.
i guess her parents are dead or not in
the picture or whatever so she just kind
of goes out there now the interesting
thing that happens here and like i said
this is kind of where the fairy tale uh
element comes into it
is that
jessie's character
is very much this kind of when she first
comes to la she's just this very like
wide-eyed innocent you know she's from
georgia
and it's like she you know says to a guy
who's sort of her boyfriend a fata slash
photographer later on that you know when
she was a kid she used to kind of like
lay out and look up at the stars and she
thought the moon was looking at her
that's kind of significant but she was
saying that she realized that she didn't
have any talent
uh you know she couldn't sing and she
couldn't write or anything like that but
she was pretty and that she would be
able to make a lot of money off that so
that's kind of like how she fell into
this line of work or whatever
so she arrives in la as i said sort of a
wide-eyed you know naive i guess you
would say
and uh but very quickly uh it comes to
pass
that
everyone in la that she interacts with
is immediately
taken with her almost like she has some
kind of
power
and that power is kind of implied to be
is because one because she's really
young she's only like 16 years old and
also because her beauty
is seen by all of the characters as
being pure as in
she's not like manufactured she's like a
very natural looking beauty because
there's like a lot there's a lot
of um stuff in this movie about
her being
uh this kind of pure like purity natural
beauty as opposed to all these other
women in la that have had all this work
done and stuff like that and it's like a
contrast between those two things
so she shows up at like this agency with
christina hendricks from mad men to
having like a little cameo there is kind
of the head of the agency or whatever
that interviews her
and um she basically sets her she's like
yeah you've got it
and uh you know whatever that is that
indefinable quality that makes a star
and she's like you know you're really
going places so they so immediately like
all of this stuff starts to happen
um there's also another major character
played by jenna malone whose name is
ruby
and she is a makeup artist
and she
pretty quickly like pretty much of the
first scene of the film very clearly has
some kind of designs either sexual and
or otherwise uh toward jessie
and basically gets jessie to go to this
really hip like party at this big
nightclub where ruby introduces her to
two other models whose names are sarah
and gigi one of them is played by um
that [ __ ] that really tall blonde what's
that girl's name i can't remember that
really tall blonde woman that was in mad
max fury road she was one of the brides
the pregnant one um yeah because i was
the whole time i was watching the neon
demon i was like god damn it where's
i've seen that woman before and i knew
her voice um and then i realized oh yeah
it was mad max fury road because you
know i've seen mad max fury road so many
times and it's like she was very
familiar to me uh but it took me a
minute to like kind of uh put those two
things together so
immediately you're kind of letting this
is why i'm saying that this is kind of
like a fairy tale type movie because
ruby sarah and gigi
are essentially
this isn't spelled out outright
but they seem like a witch's coven they
seem fascinated with jessie with her
innocence with her natural beauty
but they also
seem to want to
possess her or destroy her or something
like that so it's a so the first like
half of the movie is kind of this really
you're not really entirely sure what
their
motives toward her are like you can kind
of suspect but
just the way they're kind of like acting
toward her is like really interesting
now it gets to a point where jessie
because she has this indefinable
purity essentially she starts kind of
like
plowing ahead of all these other models
uh that have been there for longer
and kind of know their way around but
they're a little bit older a lot of them
have had work done and stuff and even
though they are also very beautiful
because she is just so young and pure
and natural it seems like everybody
photographers you know fashion designers
stuff like that are just
riveted by her and so she's kind of like
getting jobs that a lot of the other
women had wanted and so a lot of
resentment starts to build up
and as i said even though this isn't
kind of
th this is more like a symbolic or like
a subtext than it is overt
the three women
that uh initially kind of like meet her
or you know kind of interact with her at
the party that are kind of like a coven
it almost kind of gets to a point where
the entire movie almost becomes
like this sort of ritual
where
they are trying to
take from her whatever it is that she
has
that they don't have so
in that sense they do actually want to
possess her possess the power that she
has so as i said during the first half
of the film there's kind of like some
weird scenes in there too that seem
random but like the more you think about
them the more they kind of fit in with
this whole entire theme like jessie is
living at this kind of seedy motel
uh the motel manager is played by keanu
reeves actually uh he's playing like a
super like kind of
borderline well not even borderline like
a like a pedophile kind of creep so so
there's that uh he's great in it by the
way it's not he's not a huge role he's
just like in two or three scenes but uh
but it's always nice to see him so
there's one point where she comes home
to her hotel room and there's actually
like a wild cat in her room and it's
like torn her room all up so as i said
there's these kind of things that are
happening that hint toward the occult i
guess in a way but it's not real overt
there's kind of like these occult
trappings or like witchcraft or you know
maybe that was a shape shifter or maybe
that means you know what i mean so
there's that kind of stuff going on now
there comes a point as i said prior to
you know this one point in the movie
which is about at the halfway point i
think if i'm remembering it correctly
uh there's this big fashion show which
all of the mod like all of the models
are trying to you know get into and
jesse basically waltzes into the place
and the fashion designer the guy is kind
of like yeah you're it you're gonna like
close the whole show you know you're
gonna be a star whatever and all the
other girls are really really pissed
about this now at this point there's
like a really long like visual sequence
of
jessie um kind of putting on this big
like elaborate like black gown and
everything like that and then kind of
they never show her going down the
runway or anything like that it's weird
because this movie even though it's said
in la it's very
the way it's shot is like really cool
because it's like really like
sterile it's almost kind of like there's
nobody else around but like the main
characters
so it gives it this kind of like
surrealistic kind of vibe to it which i
actually really really dug i will say
too that the score for this is fan
[ __ ] tastic i love the score the
visuals of this and you know the
marrying of the visuals to the score and
everything like that was just really
kind of like
you know hitting all my my happy buttons
like i just really really loved all the
imagery in this just gorgeous gorgeous
looking movie gorgeous sounding movie um
as i said you know
people could complain that it's style
over substance okay fine you know that
the characters are not all that complex
which yeah i don't think i'd agree with
that but okay uh that it's thinner on
plot but as i said i don't really think
that's was the main thrust of the movie
i'm sure he was trying to make a
statement about
about beauty and about you know and
almost kind of like the the lengths that
people will go to the lengths of
particularly women will go to to have
uh you know to possess this kind of
power where everyone is looking at them
whether you know like the most beautiful
woman in the world or whatever and it's
just like what some people will go to to
get that to get that attention to get
that stardom and so you know and
basically it's kind of like another sort
of
hollywood you know chewing up
women and spitting them out type of
thing
so it's that kind of thing too which
like i said that's it's not a new theme
it's like there's been a lot of movies
made with that theme
but you know there there's been lots of
movies made with lots of themes and it's
like no one's complaining that it's like
oh is another one like that
you know how many zombie movies have we
had at this point i'm just saying but i
mean if you're gonna do something like
that
if you make it as beautiful and as
gordon's just like such a great like
experience as this one was then i don't
have a problem with that at all so
uh during this fashion show in which
like i said you don't see anybody else
you don't see her really walking the
runway it's almost kind of like
she's coming out in these you know
there's there's a lot of like triangle
symmetry or a symbolism which like i
said is kind of um make it harkening
back to like occult uh type symbols it
it and giving the sense that like this
whole movie is like a ritual essentially
where
she is simultaneously jesse is
simultaneously uh you know the
sacrificial victim perhaps of these
three other women who are essentially
like a covenant of witches
but she's also coming into her own
power possessing her own
you know coming to the realization of
how beautiful she is and how she can use
that to her advantage how she becoming
uh the word she uses dangerous uh
because when she first arrives in la
she's like i said she's very innocent
she seems very naive um you know she
seems very humble and very sweet uh but
after this one particular uh set piece
where she's at this uh fashion show and
she's walking through all these
triangles and there's all these mirrors
and she's like you know kissing herself
in the mirror it's almost kind of like
she becomes a different person she's
come into
her narcissism i guess and is and has
owned it and possessed it prior so after
that point she almost turns it like she
almost turns into a different person in
the sense that now she is
you know empowered sounds like a
positive word and it's really not
positive because
she has essentially gone over to
the dark side of you know of this
fashion designer whose name is sarno and
like the other models
who their whole philosophy of life is
beauty is the only thing that matters
and you know she has pretty much come to
accept the fact that because she is
beautiful
therefore she has worth if she was not
beautiful she would be worthless and she
has accepted that truism in the course
of the movie and uh so at that point
like her boyfriend
who still see who still like trump tries
to argue with uh the fashion designer
sarno saying it's like well you know
isn't it what's inside that counts but
then sarno kind of makes the point it's
like you know if she hadn't been
beautiful you wouldn't even have talked
to her in the first place even to get to
know her so you're kind of a hypocrite
so a lot of that kind of stuff is going
on as well
now after this point when she has become
when she has become narcissistic i'm
assuming uh you know seeing this movie
through the lens of
you know it's all a ritual i guess at
this point she had to come into this
narcissism
and lose her former innocence
for the ritual to work i guess
because from this point forward it
becomes a much more straightforward
horror movie
in the sense that she starts having a
nightmare she has a nightmare that uh
keanu reeves the motel manager the
sleazebag uh that he like
he comes in her room and is like
sticking a knife in her mouth you know
like it's very phallic and uh when she
wakes up from this stream uh her door
knob is like rattling and she's like
freaking out and she is able to keep him
out but then he goes into the next door
uh motel room which he has previously
mentioned is occupied by a 13 year old
runaway girl and uh proceeds to
brutalize her there they don't show that
uh but you know you can hear it
from the other room
uh at which point jessie freaks out and
she calls uh her friend the makeup
artist ruby and ruby lets her stay
at her house which is kind of like a
mansion even though she says it's not
hers she says she's just house sitting
but they never really
you're led to believe that it actually
is hers but you're not really sure why
she's lying about it so at this point
ruby who is just as obsessed with jessie
as everyone else's tries to make a move
on her but jessie who is still a virgin
uh pushes her away
and uh at this point like i said i think
this was the this was the scene after
this where a lot of people maybe got
upset and like walked out and stuff
because at this point because ruby has
been sexually rejected by jessie
she uh goes to work at her second job
because she's not only like a makeup
artist for models and fashion shows and
stuff she also um
is a makeup artist at the morgue
and uh just so happens that there's a
corpse in there that looks kind of like
jessie the in the sense she kind of has
blonde curly hair she kind of looks
similar
and uh you know
there's a scene where uh
she um you know
masturbate through the corpse so
what so i'm just i'm just saying it's in
there so uh you know what i mean
and i gotta say jenna malone like uh
kicked ass in this one because i feel
like a lot of actresses would not uh
have gone there
it's not super
graphic but i mean it's
you know it's suggestive enough that i
can see how most people would be like ew
you know what i mean because it is kind
of gross but
like i said
it didn't upset me that much but i could
see how like it would upset that people
so that was so like i said there there
is a scene like that there so just be
warned so at this point uh what ends up
happening after that is that
when
ruby uh comes home her and sarah and
gigi have decided okay well now is the
time that we're going to
you know
get to the culmination of our ritual i
guess if you want to like say it that
way so they basically uh push jessie
into an empty swimming pool break her
legs and then they go down there and cut
her up and eat her
and
it's implied uh pretty strongly
that by eating her
they have taken
whatever power it was that she possessed
that made everybody
you know that made everybody be like
fascinated with her problem is though
that one of the models apparently this
is the first time that she's done this
and she can't really stomach it
literally because
she uh gets sick she starts you know
kind of getting nauseated or whatever
and then she has to run off there's
there's um there's a photo shoot
with the two of them uh you know the two
models and uh she can't she just starts
feeling sick and she has to run away and
like i said at this point she barfs up
jesse's eyeball
and then the other model just kind of
like looks and then she stabs herself
because she's like i need to get her out
of me and then the other model just very
casually leans over picks up the eyeball
out of the vomit and eats it so we're
led to believe that that model has gone
through this ritual before um you know
so every time
i guess like i said and this is an
implication and maybe this isn't what
the movie means but
i thought that because these three women
essentially were like uh you know like i
said a coven because there's a lot of
triangles and moons and you know big
cats and things like that that they're
kind of like
it has like a lot of occult trappings to
it and i think there's even a point like
near the end where
uh ruby the makeup artist is like
walking around with no shirt on and she
has like kind of all these occulty
looking tattoos so she's kind of like
the mastermind behind this so we're led
to believe that at least ruby and one of
the other models
have maybe done this before that like
every time this very young
fresh-faced girl shows up in la they
kind of like you know put their talons
into her and essentially consume her
to
get some of that power which you do see
like does actually end up working in the
end not for the one model that stabs
herself and throws the eyeball up but
for the other one uh who like i said has
presumably done this before and uh you
know starts to get work and starts to
get more notice again
even though she's a little bit older so
as i mentioned before this is definitely
definitely not a movie for everybody and
totally i can see why some people would
hate it you know i feel like uh nicholas
winding refins me
most of his movies seem like pretty
polarizing one way or the other and it's
easy to see why but
honestly there was just something about
this one that i really really dug i mean
i just
even though there's long stretches
without much dialogue even though
you know it's you could say it was slow
in the sense but i didn't find it slow
but maybe some people would
but to be honest with you i just like i
started watching it and just like from
the very first frame i was just like
riveted to the story it was like it was
almost like a hypnosis like just the
i mean the visuals help um you know the
score helps but i was also really
fascinated by
the kind of theme of it and the kind of
theme of this unspoiled beauty like
coming there and then these other uh you
know these essentially witches like
coming in like wanting to consume it so
it was almost kind of like a little bit
i guess you could say it was kind of
like the suspiria remake a little bit as
well but not quite the same because when
they remade suspiria it was kind of like
more of like a drab
uh color palette whereas this one is
much more
new retro weight new retro wave giallo
esque it's like you know everything's
like red and purple and green and hot
pink and you know and it's just kind of
you know and just like some of the photo
shoots that she does with like all the
jewels on her face and glitter and all
this other kind of stuff and it's just
like fantastic a lot of people have
compared this to black swan too which i
kind of i can see that a little bit uh
in the sense of
identity there's a lot of mirrors uh you
know narcissism that type of stuff so
if any of that like i said sounds like
something you would be into
then definitely check it out it's on
amazon prime um you know like i said it
seems like it's gotten really mixed
reviews but i re i really really loved
it and i like
weird ass movies like this more people
need to make weird-ass movies either
like i said even if they fail that what
they were trying to do
they're still interesting to watch it's
like the worst thing a movie can be is
just like boring or nobody gives a [ __ ]
about it which is why every time i hear
that a movie like this got such a
polarizing response i always immediately
want to see it because i'm curious
anything that gets that strong of an
emotion either love it or hate it
probably has something interesting you
know interesting enough at least for me
to watch it uh and this definitely does
have that um so i don't know if any of
you guys have seen it like i said it's
not a straightforward horror movie but
it is kind of like an art house
horror movie and like i said it's very
much a visual experience as well
i kind of wish i'd seen it on the big
screen but you know what are you going
to do came out a few years back and i
don't even think it played in my part of
florida so i probably wouldn't be able
to see it anyway but this is definitely
one that needs to just kind of be
experienced it's a sensory experience
but it also has like i said it has a
deeper thematic uh type of thing and
kind of like a fairy tale occult type of
uh sprinkling on top of it so if that
sounds cool definitely check it out as i
said it's on amazon prime and i think
it's also on blu-ray if you want to go
that route
but yeah i really dug it
if you've seen it uh let me know if you
loved it if you hated it if you were
indifferent toward it i really haven't
seen anybody being different toward it
but maybe you were there's takes all
kinds really but yeah talk about it down
in the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye